RETO MEIER: Good morning,
everyone.
Welcome to Android Developers
Strike Back.
Last week, we heartlessly
reviewed camera apps in the
app clinic and redesigned
those apps in
Android Design In Action.
Now it's time for the developers
of those apps to
have their say.
My name is Reto Meier.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I'm
Ian Ni-Lewis.
Today, we're lucky to be joined
by the developers of
three of the apps we looked at
last week, including IM CTO
Ramzi Risk, Glimmr developer
Paul Bourke, and Alex Drizen
of Camera ZOOM FX.
As always, we're safe in the
Android Developers bunker in
an undisclosed location.
So Ramzi, Paul, and
Alex are joining
us via Google+ Hangouts.
RETO MEIER: Also joining us is
are resident design guru,
Roman Nurik, live
from New York.
ROMAN NURIK: It's
Saturday night.
Hey, guys.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Before we meet the
developers, let's quickly
review last week's
prescriptions.
Reto, what makes a
great camera app?
RETO MEIER: Well, we
went through each
of these last week.
And really I think what it
comes down to is having
something which is really
compelling.
It's a very visual medium
so you want
everything to just work.
So, first and foremost, you want
it to look great without
contradicting the
design guide.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I think that
was something that we really
wanted to emphasize
because cameras
are an artistic medium.
They deserve an artistic
user interface.
They don't need to look
like an alarm
clock or a text editor.
But they need to not contradict
or change our
design guidelines in a way
that might confuse users.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
You want it to be something
which is a really rich
experience, but not a confusing
experience.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
RETO MEIER: I think that's
really the cake.
We want to make sure that it
supports every image in the
image gallery.
So there's a lot of these apps
which are providing filters
for photos.
We want to make sure that it
works, even if the image that
you happen to choose
is on Picasa or
some other image provider.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Sure.
Flickr or whatever, yeah.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
Hipster filters we mentioned,
some way to be able to browse
a community of photography,
which I think really helps
draw you in and understand
what the benefits are.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, that was
something that I hadn't really
thought about.
But it is a really nice bonus
to help you feel like you're
part of a larger community
and compare
your photos with others.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
And the last point which I
wanted to mention was that it
should work on devices
without cameras.
So Nexus 7 devices, anything
like that, which may not have
a back-facing camera, but it's
a really great device for
looking at photos and enjoying
that community.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now, remember,
though, we ended up adding one
thing at the end that we didn't
put on this slide.
And that is that, at least as of
Jelly Bean, which is a much
faster OS UI wise than previous
OSes from Android,
you should be able
to have jank-free
scrolling in your app.
So as I'm browsing a large
number of images--
now, of course, sometimes you're
going to see a blank or
placeholder image as
that image comes
down from the network.
But if the image has been
loaded, you should be able to
scroll up and down without
seeing any jank.
And by jank, we mean just
frame rate drops, little
pauses in the scrolling.
Some of the apps did that
really, really well, better
than our own apps, in fact.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Which is
always impressive.
So it was great to see that and
definitely something which
we are going to be looking for
in pretty much all the apps
we'll look at in the future.
I think that's going to
be a big part of it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
RETO MEIER: So let's
get started.
Let's have a look at
each of the apps.
So these are the apps that
we reviewed on Friday.
EyeMe, Glimmr, Camera ZOOM FX,
and, what was the other?
Picnik, I think.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I think you
said EyeMe again.
But it's really EyeEm.
RETO MEIER: It's EyeEm.
I don't know why I keep
saying EyeMe.
We should ask Ramzi,
see if he's willing
to change the name.
It's going to make it
much easier for me.
So, happily, we do have the
developers of three of these
apps to speak to today.
We are going to start with
Ramzi from EyeEm.
So before we do kick over to
him, I just want to show you
quickly on screen here what the
lab results were judging
by the criteria which
we put forward.
And I think the two big concerns
we had were the
ability to support every the
image in the gallery.
And I think we had a
couple of concerns
about the design guide.
And can you remember
what was the jank
factor like on the EyeEm?
IAN NI-LEWIS: I'm
sorry, I don't.
RETO MEIER: I think
it was reasonable.
But I don't think it
was the standout.
So let's get Ramzi on and let
him speak for himself.
So hi, Ramzi, can you spend a
little bit of time-- tell us a
little bit about yourself, a
little bit about the app, just
so the audience knows
who you are.
RAMZI RIZK: Absolutely, first of
all, thanks for having us.
And thanks for the review.
We can rename it to EyeMe as
soon as you guys release
support for Action Bar on--
[LAUGHTER]
RETO MEIER: That's
a fair call.
RAMZI RIZK: No worries there.
Yeah, so, I'm Ramzi.
I'm one of the engineers behind
EyeEm and one of the
four guys that founded
it originally.
Not much to say about myself.
I develop Android, among
other things.
Recently, our team has grown
over the last few months.
And now we have actually some
really awesome developers that
are taking care of most of
the Android development.
And that's why the app has
gotten so much better over the
last couple months.
But yeah, and EyeEm
itself is--
well, you can say it's a
photo-sharing platform.
But we like to think
of it as the next
generation of photo discovery.
So photo filters, hipster photo
filters are all awesome.
But what we really like
are data centers.
And what we think is that the
fact that you're taking photos
with your mobile means you have
so much more information
available to you that
you don't need to
make the user enter.
So you don't need
the hash tags.
You don't need all of that.
But you have the location
information.
You know what sort of
location it is.
And based on that, you can
always learn a little more and
make better recommendations.
And that's what we're
trying to do EyeEm.
So the idea is whenever you take
a photo, you're telling
us a little bit more
about what you
like and how you live.
And we use that, learn a little
more, and make better
recommendations so that you're
always getting nicer content
recommended to you.
And you're always discovering
content independent of the
social graph.
So it's buzzwords, topical
graph, interest
graph, all of that.
And that's what we're
focusing on.
RETO MEIER: Very nice.
And that's, in fact--
I think the key thing for me
when I was browsing through
the app was being able follow
these little bread crumbs of
links, Things that,
ooh, that's taken
at the Android building.
I would love to see how many
other photos there are.
So that, for me, was
really compelling.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
It's a very, very interesting
service.
RAMZI RIZK: And can I say
one more thing quickly?
RETO MEIER: Please, yeah,
this is all about you.
RAMZI RIZK: Awesome.
First of all, again, I want to
apologize because the app
crashed while you were demoing
it, while you were trying to
take a photo.
And this is a funny story,
because we had actually just
released that update a couple
hours before the show.
And we'd switched our location
detection stuff into the
repository that you
have on Google
Groups, the Protips location.
So we were sort of
inspired by that.
And we tested it, and it was all
OK, except in the case of
latitudes that were
minus 120, 122.
So basically--
yeah, and thanks for reporting
it because otherwise we
wouldn't have found that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You're
very welcome.
RAMZI RIZK: It was pretty
cool of you.
RETO MEIER: Oh that's great.
That's really interesting.
So Ian's playing with
the app right now.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I like how
Googolplex is a tech
startup near you.
RETO MEIER: [CHUCKLES].
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, that's
how we roll.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
Well, I can see a lot of
duct tape in this room.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah,
there you go.
So, yeah, I think the scrolling
is definitely usable.
But, as you said, it wasn't
the standout.
There are apps that scroll
a lot better than this.
But in general, the performance
is pretty good.
And I really, really like the
way that you can see these
different categories, although
some of them are a little bit
mystifying.
Like I don't know why that
pretty girl on the train
tracks was labeled coffee.
Maybe that's some sort of
slang that I don't know.
RETO MEIER: Yeah don't
ask, don't tell.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I think that the
main objection that we had to
the UI was the camera button.
What do you think, Ramzi?
RAMZI RIZK: I absolutely
agree.
I mean, you guys definitely
know this.
It's a bit of a challenge trying
to keep up with design
guidelines in a lot of ways.
And especially, like you said,
when it comes to photography
apps, you have your
own spirit.
And we're a very design-driven
company.
So we have a team of people
that are always
tweaking this stuff.
And actually, this is one of
the things that they are
looking at.
So they started basically
looking and realized that
issue when you mentioned
it last Friday, was it?
And they are looking at
ways to improve that.
So it definitely
will be moved.
It makes sense.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Because it's
certainly tricky when you have
capacitive buttons.
Different manufacturers
do different things.
And, of course, a lot of
manufacturers do have big
fixed buttons.
But they're all getting
sued so--
apparently.
RETO MEIER: That's not working
out well for them.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
RETO MEIER: And I do notice that
this app, it does sort of
point you towards the camera
in that it has the sort of
bubbles which float around the
button to indicate, hey,
something's down here.
And you should check it out.
I wonder--
RAMZI RIZK: That's when it's
loading more content.
That's sort of the loader,
the spinner.
RETO MEIER: That's
interesting.
OK, that's kind of cool.
Roman, I know you spent a bit
of time looking at different
camera apps.
And they're all going to have
this same sort of issue as to
how do you make the button
more visible.
Do you have any tips for
EyeEm, in particular?
ROMAN NURIK: I think the one
problem I have with the
placement is that the other
half of the button, it's
negative space, basically.
I mean, you almost see the
other half of the button
overlapping with the
home button.
So when your finger jumps to
that location, your finger
jumps to where the
home button is.
I think the general location,
it's kind of hard to move it
to a completely different
part of the screen.
But having it fully on the
screen or just bigger, a
larger touch target, is going
to drastically minimize the
number of errors.
But it is just something that's
difficult, especially
for camera apps, where that is
probably the most common place
for a shutter.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Fair enough.
RETO MEIER: That's fair.
Otherwise, I think-- oh, there
was the menu button.
Yeah, Ramzi help us out.
You've got to get rid of
the menu button, man.
RAMZI RIZK: Yeah, yeah, guys.
Actually, like the stuff that
you mentioned, it's all being
taken care of.
We're doing final testing
for supporting--
well, going up to
target SDK16.
And we've dropped the camera
required, made it into a--
or camera provisions
not required.
RETO MEIER: Awesome.
RAMZI RIZK: So basically you
can use it with or without.
And what else did you mention
that we took care of?
RETO MEIER: Oh, the Picasa
gallery stuff, yeah.
RAMSEY RISK: Sorry?
RETO MEIER: Being able to edit
images from Picasa or Flickr
or wherever else.
RAMZI RIZK: That's
all in there.
That should be hopefully out
there tomorrow night.
RETO MEIER: Oh, that's
awesome.
RAMZI RIZK: And with image
scrolling, I think we might
have nailed the jankiness
part.
RETO MEIER: Oh, good.
RAMZI RIZK: It's a
big challenge.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It is really
hard, isn't it?
It's when you're dealing with
this much information, and
these bit maps are large enough
that any one of them
could just about blow
your Java heap.
We've actually spent a long
time here just trying to
figure out all of the best
techniques for that.
Dan Galpin's been working
on it in his spare time.
But, yeah, I will say that, at
least on this build, the
jankiness does seem to be
increasing a little bit,
making me think that there is
a memory leak somewhere or
some kind of resource leak.
RAMZI RIZK: That is the
problem exactly.
We do cache images, so we
have two-layer caching.
And the disk caching, it seems
that the disk caching is
causing some of these issues as
well, so the seek time on
disk, which is what we're trying
to figure out right now
and finalize.
RETO MEIER: We will definitely
be keeping
an eye out for that.
It sounds like you've pretty
already done all the things
that we thought needed
to be doing.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
We're still looking for
a pure Java solution.
But I think that for some photo
things, you actually do
have to drop down into the
Linux layer and the NDK.
Because at that point, you can
do efficient file mapping, and
you can do decoding with neon
instructions instead of with
Java instructions.
So that may be part of it.
There's also--
one thing that you have to
avoid like the plague is
allocations during
your scrolling.
Because as you acquire and
release objects, every release
is a possible GC.
RAMZI RIZK: Yeah.
RETO MEIER: So yeah, I mean,
we'd definitely love to hear
from you and from your team once
you guys have the next
launch out.
And if it is nice and smooth, it
would be great to hear some
of the hints that you guys
might have for other
developers which
are going to be
encountering the same thing.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Some of our other
guests may have some
advice as well.
Let's go ahead and take a look
at Roman's redesign.
Do we have one for that?
RETO MEIER: I don't
think we do.
For EyeEm, I think Roman
left that one alone.
I think Glimmr and
Camera ZOOM FX--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Good
the way it was?
RETO MEIER: I think so.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Except for
that camera button.
RETO MEIER: Except for
the camera button.
Roman, you didn't feel like you
wanted to spend half an
hour talking about different
ways to put a
camera button on screen?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, the thing is
to what we try to do with
Android Design in Action is we
try to look at the apps that
have a lot of UX possibilities,
like a lot of--
something that we can change
drastically and still maintain
the core app.
I think EyeEm--
I'm hoping I'm pronouncing
that right.
I think EyeEm, just like you
guys, are very close.
The only redesigns we would do
would probably be just very
small visual tweaks
here and there.
So we didn't think it was
worth spending too
much time on it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I think that
really the main critique that
I have of the interface is that
compared to some of the
other photo apps we saw, it
takes a long time to get a
full-size image.
And once I've drilled down into
the full size, then you
can't just move to another
image really quickly.
RETO MEIER: It would be nice to
have that type of scrolling
from that perspective, too.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
Like I--
in general, and maybe you could
put Ramzi back up, Deb?
I think when I'm looking at this
interface, I feel like
it's got everything
that I want.
But it's not ordered in the
order that I want it most.
So the frequency of wanting to
go from picture to picture
with some of this information is
much lower than wanting to
actually interact with some
of this extra information.
I wish I could just go
immediately to the screen and
then swipe back and forth with
pictures, back and forth with
pictures, and then up and down
for other things in the
category, or maybe even like
a drawer or something.
Because remember that
photo apps are all
about browsing photos.
RAMZI RIZK: Right.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Cool.
Well, I think that's
all the time we've
got to spend on EyeEm.
RETO MEIER: So thank you very
much for joining us today.
And thank you for a great app.
We are really looking forward
to seeing the update and
getting all of the extra stuff
that we asked for.
RAMZI RIZK: Absolutely.
RETO MEIER: Thanks, man.
RAMZI RIZK: Thank you, guys.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Thanks very
much for joining us.
RETO MEIER: All right, so next
up we're going to take a look
at Glimmr by Paul Bourke.
So this is little bit different
from some of the
other apps that we looked
at in that it's not
about taking photos.
It is about browsing
Flickr effectively.
So it's very much all about
being able to create these
rich, smooth, scrolling
experiences.
So we gave him a couple
of red marks.
But it was on stuff which
the app doesn't
actually have to do.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Why don't you
introduce yourself, Paul?
MALE SPEAKER: So Paul's actually
having some rejoining
our Hangout.
Maybe we can move on to the
next app and get the next
developer on and come
back to Paul.
RETO MEIER: Sure, absolutely.
Yeah, we can totally do that.
Lets move on to Camera ZOOM FX
while we're waiting for Paul
to get his Hangout connection
working once again.
So this is a little bit more
like EyeEm in that it is
effectively a camera
replacement.
I think the key difference here
was that Camera ZOOM FX
wasn't so much about the
community of photography.
It was more about being able to
create great photos with an
app that replaces the
native camera.
Or at least that was my
perspective, so it will be
interesting to hear Alex's.
I think where we gave it a red
mark here again was some of
the community stuff and some
issues with the design guide.
And this is, in fact, an
app which Roman and his
team took a look at.
So I think we will actually
start by having a quick look
at some of those changes.
So Roman, if you want
to talk us through.
We've just got basically the
two screenshots on screen.
Do you want to give us a very
quick rundown of some of the
thinking behind the changes
that you did?
And then we can let Alex
tell us why they are or
are not a good idea.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, so like we
said in Android Design in
Action, I think the main thing
that we wanted to do is, from
an interaction standpoint,
just to simplify
the location of things.
So we basically put the camera
and settings on the right, and
then effects, which is I
think the most awesome
part of this app.
There's so many awesome
effects.
We put that on the left
just to simplify
the model for users.
And then we started grouping
things like the shutter time
or the shutter type and
the camera settings.
We moved that, along with
the other settings,
into a single screen.
And then we made the image,
the entire camera preview,
take up the entire screen,
which I did caveat is not
possible in some cases.
But that takes up the entire
screen, And all the controls
are just overlayed.
The last point I wanted to make
was that we branded the
shutter, the shutter
button itself.
And we made it so that it was
larger and further away, if
possible, from the home button
to try to minimize the number
of accidental touches
on the home button.
So I think those are
the main things.
RETO MEIER: All right,
perfect.
So let's see if we can
get Alex on screen.
And just tell us a little
bit about yourself Alex
and about the app.
And then we can start talking
about some of the changes
which Roman and his team
suggested and how they fit
into your vision of the
app going forward.
ALEX DRIZEN: Sure.
My name's Alex Drizen.
I've been working with Android
for about three years.
Camera ZOOM FX was kind
of our first app.
And where we've kind of been
quite fortunate is to be
involved with Android right
from the beginning.
And I think Camera ZOOM FX was
actually the first app on the
Google Play Android market,
as it was then, to support
digital zoom.
RETO MEIER: Oh, nice.
ALEX DRIZEN: Yeah, so it kind of
starts in the app where we
were trying to solve
a lot of the--
I suppose the end of problems.
You're going back to the days
of the G1 and 1.5, 1.6.
So the app kind of
built from there.
Digital ZOOM was kind of what
started it, hence the name.
We were originally
Camera ZOOM.
That
RETO MEIER: Makes sense.
ALEX DRIZEN: Then we added
the FX, changed the name
to Camera ZOOM FX.
RETO MEIER: I see what
you did there.
ALEX DRIZEN: Yep, it's getting
longer and longer.
I don't think we will change
the name again.
But essentially, there are
two parts to the apps.
As you mentioned, the first half
is at the capture time,
trying to improve on the ability
that people have
whilst they're composing
and taking pictures.
So we're looking at things like
grid compositions, stable
indicators, burst mode,
time lapse.
Burst mode, for example,
we can take up to
10 shots per second.
And I guess kind of where we're
going is we look at
doing a major update
every year.
We did a major update
last August.
And-- you see my cat has
actually just come into the
frame here.
RETO MEIER: Well, it wouldn't
be a Hangout without a cat.
ALEX DRIZEN: Well, absolutely.
And this year, we actually have
another big update, which
is coming out probably in
the next few weeks.
That's
RETO MEIER: Exciting.
ALEX DRIZEN: So I would like to
kind of say thanks to Roman
and to Nick for looking at the
redesign, actually, because
it's very good timing for us.
We haven't finalized
the design.
So what you've given us is the
chance to see what we've got,
what's working, and where
we can improve.
So a lot of the points
that you raised we
completely agree with.
Starting with things like the
shutter button, we have had a
lot of feedback around that.
We are making that bigger.
We actually love Roman's design
with the wheel, the
cover effects around that.
We think that looks
really great.
We like the fact that it's
bigger, it's further away from
the home button.
We also agree that probably most
useful settings in the
app are the power features.
So changing the auto
focus mode.
So we kind of agree with Roman's
points there about
moving that to the right-hand
side of the screen.
I suppose the only issue that
we have is that because the
app is kind of two parts, we
have the capture time and the
effects screens, what actually
happens once you flip to the
FX mode, the effects becomes
the most important toolbar.
And what we try to do is have
a similar interface at the
capture time as you would
have it at the FX time.
RETO MEIER: That makes sense.
ALEX DRIZEN: So that's kind of
one of the reasons why the FX
is on the right.
But we are kind of reviewing
that to see if there is
possibly another approach
that we can take.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I can't remember
exactly what
Roman did with this.
But I remember when we reviewed
it, we said it would
actually be interesting to put
this on a view pager so I
could go back and forth between
camera and effects or
have some other--
RETO MEIER: Some easy way
to switch between.
I can see why you want to keep
the interface similar in that
once you learn it in one mode,
you don't want to have it in a
completely experience when you
switch to the other mode.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah,
so all right.
So here's a beautiful photo
that I just took.
Reto making kissy
faces at Dan.
So, yeah, Roman, what all is
wrong with this interface, or
could be changed, or
could be better?
Or Paul--
this is Paul, right?
No, this is Alex.
I'm sorry.
RETO MEIER: This
is Alex, yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Or Alex, do you
want to weigh in on what
you're changing here?
ALEX DRIZEN: Yeah, we've
actually got a whole bunch of
changes coming down the line.
We're actually moving up from
version 3.5, which is on the
Google Play now, up
to version 4.
So it is a major update.
I mean, some of the features
that are going
in there, auto rotate.
I know that's something
that you mentioned.
RETO MEIER: Oh, nice.
ALEX DRIZEN: And we absolutely
agree that
needs to be in there.
It's actually been quite a bit
of work because there's so
many controls in the
camera screen.
And we actually have to--
in terms of the actual--
it's a landscape screen, but
you have to present some
controls kind of turned
on their side.
So that has created
work for us.
But we're pretty confident,
and I'm happy with the way
that's gone.
RETO MEIER: Oh, that's great.
ALEX DRIZEN: We also, following
on from your
feedback, you talked about being
able to work on devices
with front-facing camera
only or devices
that have no camera.
That's something that will
be fully-supported.
RETO MEIER: Oh, that's
awesome.
ALEX DRIZEN: We're looking at
doing more on the holo theme.
So, again, Roman's work,
we loved it.
I showed it to my designer, and
he's kind of, yeah let's
kind of do what my design has
done and let's kind of do what
Roman's done and put
the two together.
And we think we've got something
really good.
RETO MEIER: This is
such a treat.
So we review these apps.
And then within a couple of
weeks, we're going to have new
versions of all of them
with all of the
features we asked for.
We should review more apps.
No, that's really great, man.
That's great news.
I kind of almost feel like
there's not much left to ask,
because we can just look in a
couple weeks and see exactly
what they've done.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I'm really curious
to know what sort of
problems you had or what sort
of challenges you needed to
overcome developing this
app for Android?
Because obviously it does a lot
of very complicated work.
ALEX DRIZEN: Yeah, I guess
because we were kind of there
from the beginning, we were
always trying to support right
back to Android 1.5.
And when you look at cameras,
the main complexity is in the
camera screen, not in
the effects screen.
And on the camera side of
things, it's really just
trying to pull together a
consistent app which can deal
with if everyone has different
focus modes, different scene
modes, different filters
available, the zoom works
differently on different
phones.
We actually managed to even
provide zoom on phones like
the Nexus S, which didn't
support any
kind of zoom at all.
So it really has just been
a case of just going--
at home, I have eight
devices myself.
And we have testers all around
the world who are giving us
feedback and saying
what works.
One of my test devices is not
necessarily going to work
somewhere else.
So the real the complexity has
to do with fragmentation.
But it's also been a real
opportunity because we're now
in a position where we have
over a million users all
around the world.
And we're getting this
amazing feedback from
all different places.
So it's an opportunity.
But it's an ongoing challenge.
Every time a major new device
comes out, like the Nexus 7,
before that the Galaxy
Nexus, we were
always facing problems.
And on NDK, one of the problems
that we have is that
we get the devices after you.
RETO MEIER: Good point.
ALEX DRIZEN: So often our
users will find problems
before we even have a
chance to fix them.
So it's an ongoing battle.
But we're really happy with
where we've got to.
I think this particular release,
we're focusing a lot
on the design and adding some
additional camera features.
So, for example, things like
brightness, exposure controls,
concept controls, which,
again, vary quite a bit
between devices.
Pinch to zoom, we think we've
got that working now in a way
which won't affect the
older devices.
So we're kind of happy with
the way it's looking.
We're going out to
beta next week.
So anyone who wants to come and
take part in that, just
shoot me an e-mail.
RETO MEIER: I suspect that
we'll get some takers.
We're kind of running out of
time a little bit, but I did
want to dig a little bit deeper
into what you talked
about having testers
all over the world.
So I think with a camera
replacement app, as you say,
you're going to be right on the
forefront of really having
to test on a lot of different
hardware, because there are
just a lot of different
cameras.
So are those people who work as
part of your organization?
Or do you have a public alpha
testing group of people who
you send out to test
the app on a lot
of different hardware?
ALEX DRIZEN: We have a group,
who every time we go to beta,
they're pretty much our
core group of testers.
And that's going to be
between 10 and 15.
And then, in addition to that,
what we do is, once we are at
the stage where we're ready to
go to do beta, we do invite
people through channels
such as this.
Or when people e-mail our
support desk, we will kind of
say, actually, the feature
you're requesting, that's
something we've worked on.
Would you be interested
in seeing the
beta for that feature?
And nine times out of 10,
they're going to say yes.
Send it to me straight away.
If someone's emailed you
recently, you know that they
have an active interest
in your app.
And the fact that they're taking
to you, you know that
they're going to spend the time
looking at it giving you
valuable feedback.
So, to be honest, it's
never been a
problem getting testers.
That's never been a
problem at all.
I suppose having enough time
to spend on each case is
probably more challenging.
RETO MEIER: I can see
how that would work.
I mean, as a user, that's
what you really want.
You email the developer and
go, yeah, this thing isn't
working on my phone.
Or I want this feature.
And to get that email back
going, yeah actually, we've
fixed that.
Do you want to beta test it?
Is kind of an awesome
experience.
Maybe it's because
we're geeks.
But it certainly tells me the
developer cares about the app
and cares about the community
of people developing it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, I think as
a developer, feeling like
you've got a community
behind you has got
to be a great feeling.
So bravo.
We are just about out of time.
Was Paul able to get in?
MALE SPEAKER: Paul was unable
to join the Hangout.
I think it had something
to do with his Tablet.
RETO MEIER: I think he was
joining us via a device rather
than a computer, which
is impressive
that it can be done.
It's unfortunate it
didn't work out.
But we will try and get some
feedback from Paul and maybe
share it on G+ afterwards.
I think it would have been
really useful to talk to Paul,
because I think Glimmr was the
app which had the incredibly
smooth scrolling.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know, this
is exactly what happened.
We said, oh, maybe some people
will give us some hints about
smooth scrolling.
Boom, Paul's gone.
I didn't realize that was
this kind of show.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, he's going,
yeah, you're cutting off.
I'm going through a tunnel.
IAN NI-LEWIS: All right, let's
go ahead and wrap up then.
Thanks very much, Alex.
Thank you, Ramzi.
And thanks, in absentia, Paul.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
Thank you all for joining us.
It's really great to hear back
from you developers to find
out a lot about what the
challenges are, how you've
overcome them, and, in this
instance, especially to find
out all of the cool stuff that
you've already done.
And we'll get to look
at very soon.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, we really
appreciate everyone who's
taken the time to listen to
what we have to say and
implement design guidelines and
Android features that you
didn't have before.
That's always not only a great
way to satisfy your users, but
a great way to get the Android
development community to look
at your app and possibly even
promote it on Google Play.
So we will certainly be looking
out for these updates,
because we want to nominate
those for
featuring on Google Play.
We don't have very much
power in that sense.
But we can always at least--
RETO MEIER: We try.
IAN NI-LEWIS: --send an email.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely,
absolutely.
And I think these apps are good
enough that it's going to
be self-evident.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I think
they're fantastic.
RETO MEIER: Put them in front of
someone and I think they'll
see the benefits
straight away.
Also coming up later this week,
so on Friday me and Ian
are going to be back for the
app clinic to get the apps
which we're going to then talk
about next week on this show.
So this week, we're going to be
looking at travel planning
and booking apps.
And we're going to go back to
our desks after this and
choose the apps to look at.
So if you haven't already
nominated your favorite travel
booking and or planning
app, do run on to
the Moderator page.
And now you can find that
at the developers.googl
e.com/live/android.
Navigate your way to the app
clinic show for this Friday.
And then your Moderator page
will be right there.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And in what will
probably turn out to be a
fruitless attempt to be more
prepared, we are also going to
choose the apps for next week
tomorrow so that we'll have a
week to look at them.
So if you have any specific
ideas for--
I'm sorry what was the--
RETO MEIER: I have no idea.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You should go look
and look at our Moderator
and find out what we decided
next week is going to be.
RETO MEIER: Indeed, indeed.
IAN NI-LEWIS: What were we
saying about being prepared?
RETO MEIER: That we we're going
to try and do it and
fail miserably.
So I think we nailed that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The intro
to this show went
well, didn't it?
RETO MEIER: It did.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The first couple
minutes, they were good.
RETO MEIER: I'm happy that we
went that far at least.
And then, of course, we've
got the games review.
And I don't know who's
going to be with Dan.
And I don't think we should
even try to guess.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know what?
The entire game show tomorrow
is going to be a potluck.
It's going to be very
interesting.
RETO MEIER: That's something
to look forward to.
Let's see, so, yeah,
that's it.
Again, thank you to our
developers for joining us, and
to Daniel for engineering the
show, and to Roman for joining
us all way from New York,
where it's late in the
afternoon by now.
And I'm surprised he hasn't
already gone home.
My name's Reto.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I'm Ian.
RETO MEIER: And thank you
again for joining us.
IAN NI-LEWIS: See you later.